hello and welcome to another video mini
series within the python stocks and
mathematics
tutorial video series this mini series
is going to be concerning the shonde
momentum oscillator
so the shawnee momentum oscillator
it's mainly used for
finding overbought and oversold
situations now it's going to be a little
bit different from your rsi obviously
overbought and oversold immediately we
think of rsi
the cmo differs because
what it does is it actually looks at the
the
the force the push in each direction it
looks at that push individually so
upward pushes and downward pushes
generally uh signals from the cmo here
we've got if it's greater than 50 it's
considered possibly overbought and if
it's less than negative 50 then it's
oversold so and obviously it fluctuates
over the zero line and crossover over
the zero line suggests
obviously buy and sell points
usually uh the shining momentum
oscillator is going to be just one
single line uh but a lot of people will
also plot up the simple moving average
of that cmo line and then you can kind
of treat um treat it as like a signal
right so what i'm going to go ahead and
do now is show you guys an example uh
both of just this the single line then
also of the
simple moving average line as well
and actually i guess before that uh let
me show you guys the calculations so the
calculation of the shiny momentum
oscillator
is going to be the following here
although i will just say sou equals the
sum of up movements and then sod is the
sum of down movements so the cmo is
going to say what is the sum of all the
up movements minus the sum of all the
down movements divide that by the sum of
all up movements plus the sum of all
down movements and then multiply
whatever that fraction is times 100. now
movements right is kind of inherently
just kind of means and brings along with
it that there's some sort of time frame
usually uh people are going to use a
time frame of 10 so they're going to
consider the last you know 10
10 open high low close prices looking at
um and actually in our in our scenario
we use just close prices so usually
whenever there's like a single line and
a single bit of data people just use the
close price so sorry i misspoke
um so close prices so a time frame of
like the last 10 closed prices and then
from price number one to number two did
we go up or did we go down and if we
went up that would be an up movement how
much of an up movement was that and so
on you continue adding them
so now let me show you guys uh some of
the examples from the cmo
so this is that charting application
that we made
there's a whole series dedicated to this
charting application if you want to know
exactly how to make this charting
application what we're going to be
talking about in this video and this
entire series is really all about uh
each indicator since there are just tons
of these indicators
so this is the bottom one right here is
our cmo
and so at the 50 mark we drew a red line
just to kind of denote hey this would be
an over over uh overbought scenario
possibly
and then we drew a green line at the
negative 50 mark
to denote hey this is quite possibly
oversold
now
it just so happens that we just left
this top uh indicator slot uh in its
natural state which was an rsi which is
what we used we used rsi up here and
macd
down here so it just kind of worked out
that we're uh we do have an rsi to
compare to but as you can see uh it
follows the rsi line pretty similarly i
mean there's some stuff where you know
like the peak the mountainous peak over
here is a little different than this
mountainous pekina but as far as
directional movement they're very
similar but their trajec trajectory does
differ uh quite often so it's it's kind
of interesting to compare the two
where um you know they either they move
up and down at similar times but how
much they move up and down uh differs
quite a bit um so anyway this is an
example with just the line but now what
we can do is we can also let me get out
of this and the other thing that we can
do
is plot it up with a simple moving
average so let me go ahead and
make that change for us
and now when we plot the same apple
stock again let's say
bring it over now you can see that we
have
the uh
the simple moving average line is this
like cyan line so each time there's a
crossover it's a warning right so as the
cmo crosses over our simple moving
average it's kind of like that would be
seen as kind of a warning like maybe get
out
um and then same thing as we continue on
um
you can see also when it crosses up
words you know that okay well maybe this
would be a time to to get into this
stock and then obviously here you would
be thinking about getting out but
probably not really until like this
point here you know um but anyway apple
just kept going up anyways
so
this is our cmo indicator uh this is
kind of the idea of it
so in the next video what we're going to
be doing is calculating this within
python and then the video after that
we'll actually be charting it in
matplotlib
so anyway stay tuned for those videos as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support and subscriptions and until
next time